[Music]
yo
mark german only drops bombs
he only drops bombs there's a reason we
had him on the waveform podcast and
there's a reason we had him on the
channel to talk about the future
of the iphone possibly not having ports
there's only one person i trust
at this level with this sort of
reporting at this moment
and it's mark german so on friday chill
friday afternoon he dropped
several bombs with a lot of information
and this is all still technically rumors
but about sort of the
alleged products and things that apple
is working on for the next
year or so 2021. and i'm just going to
warn you right off the
a lot of it is too good to be true a lot
of it sounds
too good to be true so i'm just gonna
just preface the whole thing with that
you know it's a very reliable source but
i wouldn't
bet my happiness entirely on it but i'm
just saying
there's a lot of good stuff so i just
figured i would go through this stuff
one by one and sort of break it down on
what the rumor is
and then my reaction and maybe some
extra details and hopes and dreams i
might have so
let's just buckle up and as philip
defranco would say let's just
jump right into it so okay let's start
with the laptops we already have
of course all the new apple silicon
stuff happening over the course of the
next year to
those rumors of an alleged new 14-inch
and 16-inch
macbook pro in the works with apple
silicon
and uh there's a couple parts to this so
first of all this would be our first
look at
a new upgraded apple silicon in a higher
end mac than just the baseline they
started at the baseline with the macbook
air
and the macbook pro that i love so
dearly and have
raved about and that many people have
but this would be our first look at a
higher end version
in the machines that typically have a
dedicated gpu see as good as these
m1 macs have been they are really good
at replacing the baseline models that
didn't need gpus
the 16-inch macbook pro currently with
an intel chip
still destroys the m1 max
in the gpu department so if you need
heavy graphics computing
you still need to get a mac with a
dedicated gpu
so when these come out this will be our
first look at whether they
just build a massive integrated gpu in
or they continue to support discrete
gpus
it'll be a first chance to see how they
do that then number two they will have
similar designs but a little more
squared off potentially and then with
new displays that are both
brighter and higher contrast now when i
read this
i read micro led so we've been waiting
to see micro led and a lot of their
higher end displays
for a little bit now i think the ipad
pro comes to mind right away because
they've had an oled iphone
and they haven't switched to an oled
ipad but micro led
is about as close as it gets to oled
without actually going oled with each
individual pixel
is its own light source with micro led
you have a lot of
tiny local dimming zones and that
equivalates to
you know much deeper blacks and much
less
glowing and blooming and things like
that so it's
almost oled and i think it makes sense
to see this sort of stuff in the
high-end versions with all the hdr push
we've seen lately
i would actually have to just say i've
been considering
moving to an hdr workflow on this
channel
for a while now the pro display xdr
supports it
youtube supports it these cameras
support it it's just getting everything
together in one pipeline that works
that is a challenge but it makes sense
and i'd be looking forward to
some pretty sweet displays here but then
number three for these laptops the rumor
indicates the return
of magsafe charging
where it all started magsafe this would
be a pleasant surprise for me
i'm sure a lot of you remember the
original magsafe which was like this
little pill-shaped port which was just
for charging but it was magnets
and it was safe that's just what it was
for so if you kick the cable out the
side of the laptop when tripping over it
it would just fall out the side and the
laptop wouldn't crash with it
now with the magsafe we have in the new
iphones it's
it's a magnet yes but it's not quite as
safe as the old mag safe you could still
rip the whole phone off the desk if you
trip over the cable
but i'm looking forward to seeing a new
version of magsafe
back in the laptops and the rumor says
it should enable some sort of faster
charging which sounds pretty sweet
but i imagine they will also still have
a bunch of usbc ports on the sides of
the laptop so if you do still want to
use one cable to charge everything which
i'm kind of close to being able to do
now you should still be able to do that
but i think the magsafe
way will be the cool way and the faster
way and then last but not least with
these rumored new macbook pros is no
touch bar
to which i say good riddance but it was
kind of
really interesting to see i tweeted
about this and uh first of all it's kind
of funny that
all of these new rumors kind of feel
like we're just going backwards to like
the 2015 macbook pro old keyboards get
rid of the touch bar
bring magsafe back which is is great but
on the touch bar it seems very
polarizing so i'd say about
75 of my replies were saying great
good riddance get rid of it there was
nothing good about the touch bar
never used it hated it and then maybe
20 of people were kind of indifferent
like oh no my touch bar fine i won't
miss it but all right
and then five or so percent of people
loved the touch bar and really wanted to
keep it and are like sad to see it go
which is interesting i don't know if the
display or the uh discrepancy would be
quite the same
among all users but it's just funny in
my replies maybe let me know in the
comments which
which group you're in i for me i didn't
really
like the touch bar that much it's fine
but it didn't really ever live up to the
potential
that it had and so i'm sure to get rid
of extra cost
getting rid of the touch bar is a
no-brainer but anyway that's the
high-end laptops
overall seems like a pretty sweet start
then let's talk about the desktops and
let's start with the imac so the rumor
is
the new imac design is right around the
corner so
the imac design i've said this for a
while you can watch my review
on the last intel imac the design
it's fine but it is old it's got
big bezels top sides bottom huge
chin and it's just not quite in the
aesthetic of the current
apple design so the rumor is we'll have
an imac come out that looks a lot like
the pro display xdr which is to say
boxier
much thinner bezels and well a little
more clean looking and so they will of
course also have the new apple silicon
and again
high-end desktop stuff so that begs the
question still about gpu support what
that situation will look like and i am
kind of thinking low key this may be
one of the more important computers that
they're working on with apple silicon
we already know most mac users are using
mac laptops
but they have the mac mini the imac and
the mac pro those are
their entire desktop lineup so the imac
ends up being where a lot of people fall
who just want an all in one
and uh i think they gotta get it right i
think they know that but they really
want to nail that
as far as value and performance to sort
of
dominate the all-in-one category so this
isn't even in the rumors but i'm kind of
hoping for things like
an sd card slot to still be there on the
side a couple of ports on the side
instead of the back the ports on the
back of the monitor it's good to have
them but
the imac i i just got tired of reaching
around
back here so often i would have loved to
see some stuff on the side but
that's not in the rumors that's just me
hoping for stuff
we'll see what they do but then last but
not least there is a new
mac pro rumor in here among all of
mark's reporting
and see the mac pro that we already got
was you know
it's got the intel chip and everything
but that was also already a very
long time anticipated product the mac
pro was very questionable about
you know this just trash can design
these thermals are they are they
not like caring about the pro market
anymore when they finally drop this mac
pro we all in
okay they're still up to it there's
still some good stuff here but now
apparently apple is working on an apple
silicon
mac pro that's less than half of the
size
of the current mac pro and is sort of
nostalgic
for the the power mac g4 cube so if
anyone remembers what the power mac g4
cube looked like
that sort of size and shape in a new
apple silicon mac pro now hearing that i
have
so many questions so many more
speculative
thoughts bouncing around my head but i
think the main one
is is this form factor supposed to be
better than the current intel mac pro
or just a cheaper version
of an apple silicon desktop like
somewhere between the mac mini and the
intel mac pro
is it supposed to be above the top of
the range or somewhere in the middle
that's the main question now as i
speculate all this there's also mention
of a new display
that is a lower priced version of the
pro display xdr so an external monitor
that's not nearly as expensive as this
i guess it would be a six thousand
dollar monitor with a thousand dollar
stand
infamously um and that makes me
think it will launch alongside this
newer
smaller mac pro and that they will both
be
cheaper than their currently existing
counterparts
does that make sense so apple gets back
into the pro desktop market with a
way too expensive for most people and
way overkill for most people
intel mac pro and pro display xdr but
then can leverage their
cachet can leverage their tech and build
something
awesome in a smaller box that they can
still call a mac pro
but that now has apple silicon that now
has better thermals
that now has hopefully great graphics
and is cheaper than the current
extremely expensive mac pro anyway that
is definitely what the
creative inside of me is most excited to
see because i
like i said when we first saw these new
macs with apple silicon i
immediately went to the top i was like
what does the fully unlocked
best version of this look like and it
looks like
that mac will be it we'll see oh and
then uh some iphone stuff
we all probably already know apple makes
iphones they're
a bit of an iphone and accessories
company so allegedly this year
was basically an s year for the iphone
which is about what we expected meaning
a bunch of
minor updates nothing too crazy now the
main change they're working on is an
in-display fingerprint reader
and knowing how many years we've had
these around and how much better they've
slowly gotten
i'm not shocked by this i'm just kind of
bracing myself
for that to be an excuse to get rid of
something else
i don't know what that other thing will
be but i've made an entire video about
the port situation now there's no
mention in here in this article
of any high refresh rate display and i'm
not sure it would even be
worth mentioning like it's such a common
accepted feature at this point that it's
kind of weird that the iphone
doesn't have one i really hope the
iphone 13
or 12s whatever it's called does have
120hz display
alongside the ipad and as many other
things as they can but
it's not mentioned so that's worth
mentioning but i'll just say you should
definitely watch that entire video i did
with mark german
on the idea of a portless iphone and how
realistic it may be that the next iphone
that comes out
has no ports i'll link it below one
other thing
is mentioned that apple's working on
a foldable iphone now this is this is
not
a next year or so thing this is a thing
they've been in the background working
on
i'm sure i imagine there's prototypes
floating around apple campus
actually probably locked in a room
downstairs somewhere but
we probably won't see an iphone fold
anytime soon it's just
it's just curious that the alternate
form factor universe has been expanding
and growing and turning into something
really interesting
and i i i look forward to the day apple
joins in
and to a lot of people legitimizes
that whole space because we've got
foldable phones we've got rolling stuff
we've got swiveling stuff
and i think the day apple joins that we
start to see a lot more but that's
coming in the future
apparently they also do plan to launch
air tags sometime this year we already
we just saw an equivalent from samsung
that works with samsung galaxy phones
i think that's a missed opportunity i
think they could have made something
that works with
as many things as possible and just
works best with galaxy phones but
expect that i think sometime this year
and also mark mentions
a much faster much faster ipad pro
with mini led which it's hard to imagine
an ipad pro much faster it's already
leaps and bounds ahead of a lot of other
tablets
but i think the big innovation will be
mini led we've wanted that thing to go
oled for so long mini led again like i
said is as close to that
as we can pretty much get right now nice
i'm just gonna throw in one more thing
for fun this isn't part of mark german's
uh series of leak bombs but uh
apparently apple is researching a new
light absorbing black finish for
macbooks
which i gotta say i i really like the
way the icon skin looks
on the back of my macbook pro right now
but also matte black
laptops can we bring those back apple
you used to do it you could do it again
but anyway that is
that is pretty much it like i said it's
a lot to take in there's new laptop
stuff
there's new imac stuff there's new
desktop stuff and there's new iphone
stuff
all in here i'm going to leave all the
links below if you want to check that
out and read the full articles shout out
to mark german again
for his reporting over the years but i'm
curious what you're
most interested in for me it's that mac
mac pro i should say
but for you let me know in the comments
rap touch bar
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one
peace